Did you ever know that in 1998, "Psycho" was released from "Vince Von" in a role
Norman Bates? - I think we each have a special trap tied to it
The film failed at the public and monetary level
It is almost just re-making a snapshot of the original, making it a good case study
In knowing why the original was very good, we can compare the two to reflect
The nuances between them and find out why those differences are important, and how they are made
From the original "Psycho" much better.
Let's talk specifically about the end. How did the original film end?
What did Hitchcock leave with him? Most people remember Norman Bates' look to the camera however
But it actually ends up with the car pulling out of the mud. The snapshot keeps on
Bad taste in our mouths because we know what is in the trunk of the car
Not to mention that she was photographed from the center as she headed towards us
Movie Replay The end begins the same way but ends with a panoramic motion
To reveal the landscape while the Tatar rises. Which completely destroyed the end
We are supposed to end up feeling disgusted and uncomfortable but in a panoramic motion
Brings us back to the world with its familiar sights and cars moving through it
The end of the original "Psycho" is much better because it is disgusting.
If the camera moved away from this teasing picture and finished
In the familiar situation, we emerge from the story and the case of murder and return again
To society
This is not the correct way to end the movie. The end of "Psycho" replays are closer to
End of the film where driving in the sunset. This kind of footage is where
We emerge from the original story and return to our world.
It is also a snapshot where our main characters - who have gone through a misfortune of some sort -
They are actually moving away from the camera to complete their journey
This type of finish is a lot of Western films but it is still widespread in
Modern films only with a few modifications
At present it can be a car instead of a horse or street corner instead of
Beautiful sunset. It is a very comfortable end. See something familiar
It also makes you cinematic that the story is over and we're back to
The real world
"Twelve Angry Men" ends with the men - who gathered to speak by virtue
Innocence of the child - return to the real world. A world where the American justice system
His role and people are convicted only if they have already committed a crime
It's a comfortable end and integrates with a theme that inspires a good feeling that is
Even the most stubborn people can listen to logic and change their views
Not very easy or very nice. But do not say that all the ends are driving in
In the sunset leave a good feeling.
What about a serial killer
Back to society? Now this is a scary end. - I wish we could chat more but ..
- I will meet an old friend at dinner. Similarly, a door closes at the end represents
Beautiful code to finish the movie
This is a material chapter now. Where the door literally closes on
Adventure
Also very common. You can even use it to separate two main characters inside
The story, which Francis Coppola has done and perhaps is the film's last ending
in history!
"The Searchers" also has a start shot at the door entrance
John Wayne enters the desert. Then we have the end shot showing him as he goes
Across the same entrance. This end symbolizes that our hero returns to
The wild that came from them.
Another common end: is when there is a link between the end shot and the start shot.
A great video, with a montage of start and end shots side by side,
You can find it on the Vimeo site, many of which are related to each other.
The goal of this type of end is to show a snapshot similar to the start cat
But now that you've seen the movie, it should be a different feeling
The start shot is the first impression the film tells of his story. And the film
It ends with something similar to what it started. The last shot is always what
Will give a different feeling because after the film tells his story, the shot became
With a completely different meaning. In the second part of "Godfather", the shot is the same but Michael Corleone
No longer. In the film "Gone Girl" he uses a violent perception
Referring to his wife.
- I imagine I smashed her beautiful head empty her brain to try to
Get answers! In the last shot we know why. It's fun to think about movies
Because the end can carry some of the main ideas of the film. the difference between
Between the start and end shots is that the start shot gives a hint of these ideas
While the end shot confirms it, it looks like the director is lighting
The most important part of the film
So go and watch the end of your favorite movie again. Maybe looking for a code
What do you think the badminton symbolizes in "Forrest Gump"? There is no right or wrong answer
But we know what the director wants you to notice. What the movement
Which leaves you with it?
This is the most important feeling in the film. Because what you come out of
The showroom is what really matters.
So try it out. This leaves you with the sarcastic ending of "Simpsons"
For the end of the film "Godfather". Because I love "The Simpsons"
thanks for watching
Translated by: Zakaria Said